I've got some video to play for you today.
That is nothing short of tragic.
Donald Trump had
this unhinged Mager rally in Ohio last week.
It was riddled with lies, attacks on political
opponents, smears, blaming everybody else
for failures, taking credit for successes
that don't even have anything to do with him.
And that was the rally itself.
But I found a video posted on Twitter yesterday,
um, of an eight year old being interviewed,
a Trumpist eight year old being interviewed,
which reminded me of a horrible video I once
saw of a brainwashed Argentinian kid talking
politics.
Although this kid at the Trump rally was far
less articulate than that Argentinian one.
Anyway, I'm looking for information about
the guy who's doing the interview, who seems
to be some kind of Christian.
You'll see him go into prayer.
He at one point puts his hand on the kid's
head to pray for him.
So let's look at the first part of the clip.
My question to you is, is this child abuse?
Are the circumstances that got this kid to
this mental state by the parents?
That is, are, is that child abuse?
Because an eight year old doesn't become like
this on their own.
And again, you'll, you'll notice if you're
watching that the moment the kid says something
about Trump being great or whatever, the pastor
puts his hand on the kid's head and starts
praying.
This is full indoctrination on a political
front, on a religious front that this is crazy.
Take a look
right over here.
I get out of the way of the folks coming up
here.
What's your name?
Say that again.
Bo gray.
What are you doing out here?
Me and my mom and named pop are sitting here
cause we're boxy.
The most greatest president in the whole wide
world stone chapel.
You just reminded me of my daughter when you
said that your Nana and Papa, God bless you
Lord.
I just pray a special blessing.
Tell me what bow is it.
Bow.
I pray.
A special blessing on bow.
Lord, I pray that you would bless him.
Keep him.
You'd make it your face to shine upon him.
Be gracious unto him.
Raise him up, Lord, into the warrior that
you happen to be.
Let this light shine out of this young man.
God, I pray in any of the darkness that wants
to come, Lord, that your light would just
shine through it.
Man, I'm glad to meet you though and I'm glad
that your pop and that is it.
Nana Naynay, your Papa and your nae nae brought
you out here.
How old are you?
I'm eight years old.
I go to school in Bollinger elementary.
Now this isn't about this kid.
I want to be clear.
This kid is a victim.
The kid doesn't see himself as a victim.
The parents don't see them as a victim.
This Christian pastor dude, who puts his hand
on the kid's head, clearly they don't see
the kid as a victim, but what happens when
this kid enters the real world?
What happens if this kid goes to college?
If that's something that's in the kid's future,
this kid's parents are the ones who likely
say college is just liberal indoctrination
because look at who they're raising, who will
eventually maybe arrive at college and be
completely unprepared for how the real world
actually works.
There's more video.
Let's watch a little bit more.
That is so cool.
And did you get to get out of school today
to come see the president?
Yes.
Is this your first time checking the app to
get to go wait to get pop pod because it's
your mom.
Your mom checked.
You had a school that didn't hurt your feelings
though did it?
You were pretty excited to see Donald Trump.
The stage is shredding everybody tray in the
seats.
They have snacks in.
They're ready to fork for the spray.
The smell.
Is this your first time to see him?
How excited are you on a scale of one to 10
excited.
I've seen Donald Trump on TV was when he became
the first present.
So when he comes out on that stage, are you
just going to go crazy?
I love it.
Anything else you want to say?
I see.
Do you play football?
I see the football shirt.
I really don't play football, but I will.
Awesome.
Hey, it's such an honor to meet you young
man and shout out to your mom.
God bless ya.
Alright, let's screen.
Let's screenshot this.
Hang on.
There's
even a little bit more, but let's stop it
there.
Notice that the kids said when Donald Trump
became the first president, might've misspoken.
Also, what, what might've his parents been
telling him to come up with that idea?
This seems like a news report, uh, characterized
in like a dystopian alternate universe science
fiction movie where everything has gone wrong,
right?
This is like, Oh, you know, in a time travel
film where someone came back and did something
that modified a future, a universe and things
went completely off the rails.
This is how it would be depicted.
Remember that the American rights says that
they're worried about the left indoctrinating
children.
Look at this video and as I mentioned, this
reminded me of an Argentinian kid named Casey
wonder who's way more articulate than this
kid, but just as indoctrinated without really
having a clue.
I'm not gonna play it for you because of copyright
issues with Argentinian news stations.
But if you go on YouTube and you just type
in Casey wonder, you'll find an interview
with this kid and the subtitles, I think will
maybe translate it.
Subtitles will help you figure out what's
going on.
We wonder why we're falling behind in math
and science.
And then we see that this kid, instead of
being in school, he's at a Trump rally with
his sycophant parents being celebrated by
the people around him, including being prayed
for by another irrational Trump supporter,
all of whom believed that Donald Trump is
a pseudo deity of some kind.
And I know that many of our instincts when
we see this, our instincts are just discussed,
Oh this, this is disgusting.
But this connects to really serious things
that have happened in the Midwest and in other
regions of the country that got us to where
we are today.
Because this is not merely cultural.
This is not merely about intelligence.
This is not merely about religion.
It's very easy for, you know, people in liberal
parts of the country to see this and to just
laugh and to say we're superior.
Look at this backward stuff.
This is the end result of a combination of
growing inequality as the rich get more and
more rich and the poor get less and less alongside
the convenient demonization of what is essentially
modernity under the guise of they want to
indoctrinate you in college and in those liberal
cities like New York and Boston.
And what's interesting is that similar economic
circumstances in Northeastern blue States
have generated progressive activists around
issues like education and other issues in
the Midwest and in other areas.
Those same economic problems, although those
problems exist to a greater degree in red
States as we've talked about, have produced
people who have gone into this hyper religious
conservative shell.
They've become voters along the issues of
abortion and religion and guns.
And it's very easy for us and it's very tempting
for us to watch this and pass judgment on
it.
But that's part of why we lost in 2016 and
we will lose again in 2020 if we just write
this stuff off.
Okay.
Even if we are logically correct when we say
children raised in an open minded Massachusetts
family will be better off in the real world
than this kid.
That may well be true, but it ignores the
reality of how things got this way and what
it will take to change them and that is the
really important thing.
We can't forget going into 2020 by the way,
if this video is a parody and I'm just missing
it, please tell me I'd be relieved to hear
that this video is merely a parody.
If you have information about who that dude
is praying over this kid touching his head,
I do want to know because it, it reeks of
all of the worst of what we are fighting against,
but again, if we just pass judgment on it,
that's not going
to help us
when